Russia's Wagner mercery groups
threatened to pull out of Ukraine's in
battle City of Bachman if Moscow doesn't
send more ammunition ahead of the group
if gaining priguzin says that without
proper supplies his troops will withdraw
or die fighting for the control of
Bahamut in eastern Ukraine's lasted for
months cave says it remains in control
of a key Supply Route into the city
now our statistics show that when we
have enough Munitions we have ex-people
killed but when we don't have enough
ammunition we have x times five deaths
so this is what I think I'm all but
ready to write up a big report to the
prosecutor General's office or the
investigative committee to look into
this and find and hold those responsible
for the deaths of thousands of Russian
men
is a journalist based in Moscow she's
joining us live from there this is an
unusual thing to admit in the middle of
a battle why is progression saying this
now and so publicly
uh that's correct well we all know that
the situation is pretty dire there and
according to progression as you
mentioned the Wagner group will lead the
front and their positions in the problem
with the supply of ammunition is not
resolved he said that in an interview
with one of the Russian military
bloggers uh Ferguson said that it had
written an ultimatum to defense minister
Sergey shoigu saying that before the
expected offensive of the Armed Forces
of Ukraine the lack of the Munitions
could lead to catastrophic consequences
for Russia uh according to preggers
forecast the offensive should begin no
later than May the 15th uh he also warns
that his Wagner group could come to an
end he reiterated that Wagner would
cease to exist in a short time due to
heavy fighting the lack of shells plus
earlier precursion as repeatedly said
that Wagner Fighters were supposed to be
um short for desertion and the New York
Times also wrote uh the Russians
storming bahoud faced execution or
imprisonment for leaving their positions
or or for desertion so the situation is
quite tense at the moment so some quick
decisions has to be made
Russians have been arrested at the very
least and prosecuted for criticizing the
conflict in the Russian military why is
it if getting is able to get away with
statements like this against so publicly
um exactly he's obviously a very
important player in this conflict and he
is an important one right now and he
positions himself as a public figure and
he doesn't hesitate to be very loud on
what's going on on the front line and
criticize the Army when he thinks it's
necessary in the past few months
pregosia has openly come into conflicts
with the Russian defense Ministry in
particular accusing the military
leadership of deliberately preventing
the shipment of shells and Munitions to
its mercenaries and in addition he was
cut off from hiring prisoners in Russian
jails uh those prisoners they obviously
placed the most important part
um in the tactics that allowed the
Wagner to advance in the bahmoud area
they were the first to be thrown into
their Salter in order to reveal the
acquiring positions of the Armed Forces
of Ukraine and also on the 14th of April
Greg ocean said a quote for the
authorities and for society as a whole
today it is necessary to put some kind
of Full Stop in the conflict and uh the
ideal option in in his opinion is to
Proclaim Russia's Victory and announce
the end of this special operation uh
that's according to you getting pregosia
Yulia thank you very much indeed that's
all about bringing us up to date from
Moscow
well at least two civilians have died in
South Western Russia as a result of
shelling by Ukrainian forces that's
according to the local Governor the
attack happened in the village of
briansk region a residential building
and houses were destroyed